jean luc mélenchon à nouveau tête de
liste pour l'élection européenne pour la
grande région sud ouest et d'invités de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp et dailymotion avec
nous c'est à dire tout à leurs côtés le
prix jean de la fp et perrine tarneaud
de public sénat qui nous rejoindront
donc jean luc mélenchon mais avant
d'évoquer le 25 mai l'élection en france
dont des députés européens
on va parler de ce 5 mai cela fait deux
ans exactement que françois hollande a
gagné l'élection présidentielle et vous
ne ménagez pas depuis c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire est ce que vous pouvez
au moins citer une de ses réussites
non rien
bano un immense blanc je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas un blanc vous me posez une
question je vous réponds la réponse est
non le mariage pour tous lâché c'est une
réussite de françois hollande ça j'ai il
a failli faire capoter le projet il l'a
estropiés en cours de route et vous
appelez ça une réussite
vous appelez une réussite la manière
avec laquelle a été géré cette affaire
le fait que le président de la
république est affaibli son propre camp
en cours de route en expliquant qu'il y
aurait une clause de conscience possible
pour les élus pour ne pas célébrer des
mariages pour tous c'est à dire avant
temps quelque chose d'incroyable qui est
que la loi ne s'applique que si on a
envie de l'appliquer vous appelez ça une
réussite
non c'est pas du tout une réussite cette
affaire a été très malmené
qui plus est sur des sujets pardon
puisque vous voulez entrer parce que
c'est vous qui cite et les réussites du
gouvernement de françois hollande mais
je vais vous aider mais tant qu'il ya
pas de réponse précise non vous ne
m'ayez pas vous m'avez posé une question
et je vous réponds vous n'avez pas à
m'aider à trouver des bonnes idées pour
françois hollande journalistes ou ou
portable de françois hollande
journaliste donc ma réponse est non
il a mené rien de ce qu'il a entrepris
d'une manière qui mérite d'être retenu
par contre les économistes de droite
peuvent le féliciter et dire bravo
monsieur hollande a réussi ce que
personne n'avait fait avant lui par
exemple repousser la retraite à 66 ans
par exemple refusé toutes les
augmentations du smic par exemple créé
la politique qu'ils appellent de l'offre
d'une manière très prétentieuse et
donner plus de 90 milliards total à ce
qu'il appelle les entreprises
c'est-à-dire les très grandes
entreprises
alors ça c'est deux sont des réussites
de droite ne demandez pas à moi sommes
de gauche
de célébrer une pareille très bien on a
bien compris alors françois hollande au
matin de ce 6 mai a demandé à être jugé
à la fin du quinquennat est ce que vous
ne voulez pas lui accorder cette grâce
jean-luc permet mais non mais non parce
que il est dangereux d'ores et déjà et
je vais vous montrer en quoi
oui je vais vous montrer pourquoi
d'abord sur le plan des relations
internationales nous l'avons entendu à
l'occasion de sa grâce à son entretien
de presse le matin de l'anniversaire de
son élection
dire qu'ils étaient disposés à
intervenir militairement en syrie
même sans l'onu dans le cadre de l'otan
c'est une première jamais la france n'a
eu une attitude belliciste de cette
nature la france a toujours agi dans le
cadre de l'onu donc françois hollande
regrette que les nord américains soient
pas intervenues en syrie et il regrette
que l'on n'ait pas fait une intervention
hors le cadre de l'onu de la même
manière sur les sujets internationaux
il a toujours aligner la france dans une
position extrémiste par rapport aux
états unis d'amérique
maintenant sur le plan intérieur sa
politique d'austérité a créé une spirale
dépressive un cercle vicieux qui fait
que plus l'activité a ralenti plus le
déficit naturellement se creuse puisque
les rentrées fiscales ne sont pas
suffisantes et plus déficit se creuse
puis il faut augmenter par conséquent il
est responsable de lane amy et d'une
poussée du chômage
absolument incroyable plus de neuf cents
par jour depuis qu'il est le président
de la république
donc ça nous pouvons le dire on va pas
attendre la fin du quinquennat pour dire
que tout ça est une mauvaise alors non
mais attendez il s'agit pas de le juger
nous ne sommes pas dans un concours de
beauté nous sommes des citoyens actifs
dans une démocratie chacun de demandes
attendait la fin du quinquennat vous
dites non d'ores et déjà et il a échoué
les yeux mais monsieur gossio attendez
une seconde qu'elle soit il est
dangereux que d'ici la fin du
quinquennat personne ne vote
qu'est ce que vous me dites monsieur
gros sur le 25 mai nous allons mettre un
bulletin de vote
le bulletin de vote contient un jugement
sur l'action de françois hollande c'est
bien françois hollande qui n'a pas
renégocier le traité européen qui
s'était engagé à négocier c'est bien
françois hollande qui a dit que le grand
marché transatlantique
il fallait le faire vite et fort et tout
de suite et le plus vite possible pour
que les gens aient pas le temps de
réagir
donc le 25 mai nous allons mettre un
butin d'autres beaucoup d'entre nous
contre cette europe et contre françois
en train de me dire
michel grossiord que je dois attendre la
prochaine élection présidentielle pour
donner mon avis mais c'est pas une
monarchie dans laquelle nous sommes
alors c'est une république de la version
françois hollande nous habitue à ces
prophéties vous l'avez noté jean avec
mélangeant le retournement ou encore
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
c'est son obsession il le répète qu'une
croyais et je crois ni à l'une et à
l'autre ni au retournement en est à la
version de la courbe du chômage c'est ce
que d'ores et déjà selon vous françois
hollande il l'avait dit d'ailleurs aux
ouvriers de michelin devraient renoncer
à se présenter en 2010 sable et ça c'est
son problème mais je ne suis pas
socialiste je ne m'occupe pas de ce
qu'il fait il fera bien ce qu'il voudra
mais je moi je m'occupe de savoir si
cette politique va produire autre chose
qu'un désastre
le premier désastre il est moral
permettez moi de vous le dire c'est que
l'idée du socialisme a été abaissée
comme jamais et jusqu'au point que pour
beaucoup de gens la gauche et la droite
c'est pareil
voilà ça c'est un désastre en naufrage
moral qui est de sa responsabilité à lui
est de cette manière il a poussé des tas
de gens hors de leurs habitudes de leurs
de leurs réflexes intellectuels et
moraux le deuxième désastre
il est social le troisième il est
national c'est à dire que la france
entend que entités en tant qu'etat en
tant que nation est en train de se vider
de son sang sans que le président de la
république lève le petit doigt
il n'a rien dit quand une entreprise
aussi importante il fait son obsession
mais qu'il a dit là ils ferment culpa il
n'a pas dit que les choses étaient assez
gré aussi grave qu elles le sont
notamment la perte de marchés
économiques jean luc mélenchon et puis
la perte de compétitivité des
entreprises
ce sont les arguments du chef de l'état
jugé bien on joue les aurait payé mais
si vous permettez je vais vous opposer
les miens d'arguments quand une
entreprise de pointe dont nous avons
besoin pour le redéploiement et la
transition écologique comme alstom se
trouve dans la situation dans laquelle
et parce qu'elle n'a pas été assez
capitalisées pourquoi la banque
d'investissement n'intervient pas pour
prendre la relève
au lieu de vendre cette entreprise soit
à son concurrent allemand ce qui serait
une catastrophe sociale et économique
soit à l'entreprise nord-américaine qui
la convoite pour des raisons qui sont
propres aux regroupements caisse ne fait
rien pour l'emploi du temps de m
mais moi je vous le pardon ne changeons
pas de sujet nous sommes en train de
dire pourquoi celui qui se prétend
obsédé par la question du chômage et qui
feraient mieux de réfléchir au lieu
d'être obsédé et bien pourquoi le
fait-il rien quand un des fleurons de
l'industrie française va disparaître que
pourquoi ne fait il rien l'état ne va
pas entrer dans le capital mais noté
c'est encore pire que tout n'est ce pas
pourquoi l'état notre heure est il pas
au capital pourquoi la nationalisation
n'aurait-elle pas lieu pourquoi notre
sidérurgie et à la baie c'est pourquoi
notre industrie électronique comme celle
qui est alcatel lucent pourquoi l'état
at il laissé alcatel s'endetter auprès
de goldman sach pour un milliard et demi
en déposant 29 mille brevets tout le
savoir industrielle de la france dans ce
domaine donc le chef de l'état a une
attitude d'abandon parce que il est
aveuglé par l'idéologie néolibérale il
pense que le marché règlera tous et qu'à
la fin ça finira par s'arranger au
passage la france est en train de se
faire rayer de la carte des grandes
puissances industrielles
la france est en train de se faire rayer
de la carte des nations indépendantes
qui sont en état d'opérer des médiations
lorsqu'il ya des conflits dans le monde
comme on le voit en ukraine vous parlez
de compétitivité il parlait de parts de
marché à qui seront les parts de marché
ont dit que c'est de cela dont souffre
aujourd'hui alstom en france non c'est
alors là vous me tendait une perche que
je vous remercie de me tendre
non alstom n'est victime que d'une seule
et unique sur le carnet de commandes
d'alstom est plein alstom n'est pas
assez capitalisées et alstom souffre du
fait que les politiques d'austérité des
états en europe interdisent des
investissements lourds dont on aurait
besoin pour la transition énergétique
mais ce n'est pas tout elle est aussi
victime de la libéralisation du marché
de l'énergie parce que comme c'est un
marché c'est le moins coûtant qui
obtient le marché par conséquent les
grandes entreprises productrices
d'électricité n'investissent pas et par
conséquent on n'achète pas les nouvelles
machines
voilà pourquoi le stum et victimes de
l'austérité et du libéralisme en aucun
cas de la compétitivité
attendez monsieur gossio c'est vous qui
avez posé le problème dites moi quel est
le problème de compétitivité d'alstom
y at il un prêt avec le coût du travail
comme ils disent non pas du tout
personne ne se plaint de sa part contre
moi je vous dit les yeux dans les yeux
il ya un problème du coût du capital
parce que si les premiers qui ont vendu
alstom avait pas siphonné la trésorerie
si monsieur bouygues après avoir
encaissé comme tous les autres
actionnaires
5 milliards 800 millions
en cinq ans qui manquent aujourd'hui
dans la caisse dalton il les a
encaissées en dividendes ne les avaient
pas pris si on avait investi vous
n'auriez pas d'affaires alstom
aujourd'hui donc c'est bien la preuve
que c'est le coût du capital
est ce que vous êtes impressionné est-ce
que vous saluer le travail et
l'implication d'arnaud montebourg dans
le dossier par exemple ce que vous lui
faites un sort particulier je ne serai
pas juste c'est un c'est une équipe
c'est un gouverneur donc si nous
regardons d'un peu près personne ne fait
rien par des mots je veux dire florange
a bel et bien été fermés que je sache
alcatel n'a pas été recapitalisée grâce
à l'action de la banque d'investissement
alstom on approche jusque-là le pays
notre selon vous est-ce que pour vous
l'arrivée de manuel valls à matignon
vous a donné l'occasion vous donne
l'occasion d'aiguiser encore plus vos
critiques déguisées encore plus je ne
crois pas parce que il y aurait une
certaine injustice
après tout le plan d'austérité de 50
milliards c'est pas le plan de valls
c'est le plan des ro de toute façon il
avait annoncé avant non valls représente
un pari politique du chef de l'état qui
a analysé les résultats des élections
municipales de la manière suivante il
s'est dit bien le peu le pays votent à
droite je lui donne comme premier
ministre j'ai de plus à droite dans mon
parti
quand je dis ce que j'ai de plus à
droite dans mon parti ce n'est pas une
appréciation personnelle
c'est l'appréciation qui avait été fait
en son temps par martine aubry elle même
qui avait demandé à valls ou bien tu
arrêtes où tu quittes le parti social
rien préféré à m je n'ai pas d'avis sur
le sujet ce n'est pas une affaire de
personne c'est une affaire de l'hymne
politique
ces personnes sont individuellement
respectable ô combien ce n'est pas le
sujet le sujet c'est quelle est la ligne
politique que l'on a plus de temps qu'on
applique la politique d'austérité
la france va dans le mur nous sommes une
nation qui moins qu'une autre a intérêt
à une politique de sous capitalisation
sous investissement sous intervention de
l'état dans l'économie
jean luc mélenchon vous appellez par des
députés socialistes rondeurs année 41
qui n'ont pas voté le plan d'économies
de manuel valls à vous rejoins composer
une nouvelle
mérité la majorité c'est ça avec un
hiver en effet le front de gauche alors
j'adore mais l'objectif ça serait quoi
de faire tomber le gouvernement
non ces deux c'est une sortie positive
parce que le gouvernement il va tomber
tout seul suffit de faire une élection
était vous savez aussi bien que moi
de quoi valls at il menacé les députés
qui ne voulait qu'ils voulaient voter
contre qui voulaient s'abstenir il leur
a dit si vous ne le faites pas nous
dissoudre on est la menace et que s'ils
disent 'on la droite et l'extrême droite
l'emportent
aussitôt on le sait on le regarde dans
les études donc moi je ne suis pas un
aventurier
je ne propose pas le saccage c'est
pourquoi je propose une sortie positive
une autre majorité à l'intérieur même
cette assemblée un autre centre de
gravité à gauche pour une autre
politique
vous avez des ralliements déjà en vue
non attendez prenons d'abord les choses
comme elles sont parce que je crois que
les commentateurs ne ne regarde pas
d'assez près ce qui vient de se passer
valls a été choisi pour réduire la crise
de confiance et élargir la base
d'actions du président de la république
à peine arrive t-il les verts quittent
le gouvernement
puis passe dans votre d'abstention à un
vote contre à l'occasion de son plan
économique
dans le même temps 10 députés 11 députés
commencent par ne pas voter la confiance
et la fois d'après il passe à 41
d'accord et là cette fois ci nous venons
en plus le valve vient en plus de perdre
le mrc autrement dit la base politique
de l'actuel gouvernement qui était
pourtant là pour élargir cette base
réduite
oui il a une majorité relative et on
nous offre comme perspective un meilleur
dialogue entre socialistes je respecte
parfaitement le droit des socialistes de
dialoguer entre eux mais honnêtement
c'est pas le sujet la france ne peut pas
être pendus à la qualité du dialogue que
les socialistes ont entre eux il faut
une nouvelle coalition est d'ailleurs
valls est en marche et d'istres mais
attendez valent ses six pattes
dissolution valls est en train de
chercher cette nouvelle coalition
il est en train de la chercher avec le
centre très traditionnellement pour la
droite du parti socialiste le centre est
l'allié naturel
moi je propose que les socialistes est
une alliance de gauche et que donc on
change entièrement le dispositif
c'est à dire qu'on tienne tête aux
allemands qu'on arrête avec la politique
d'austérité qu'on relance l'activité du
pays sur les bases du développement
écologique parce que c'est là qu'a
besoin de milliards pour faire changer
la nature de la production d'énergie
i de l'échangé etc etc voilà ce qu'il
faut faire c'est une politique qui
forment un programme
j'admets qu'on ne veuille pas mais c'est
mon devoir de le proposer
et c'est mon devoir de dire aux
socialistes qui ont mordu le trait si
vous me permettez à dire quand on décide
de ne pas voter la confiance à un
gouvernement de refuser son plan
économique on peut pas ensuite rentrer à
la maison et dire eh ben on verra la
prochaine fois de quelle manière on sera
remarqué non ils doivent eux aussi faire
une proposition positive des contacts
avec certains députés ps mais si j'en ai
je ne vous le dira
parce que ce sont des choses qui ont
besoin disons une certaine
confidentialité pour pouvoir fonctionner
alors que les dialogues
oui pour que les préventions sa baisse
mais monsieur gros sur j'insiste nous
avons tous des responsabilités
politiques devant notre pays
ce n'est pas un jeu le pays va très mal
les gens souffrent d'une manière inouïe
par conséquent les 41 ans qui ont dit
qu'ils ne voulaient pas de cette
politique économique ont le devoir d'en
proposer une autre et c'est pourquoi je
leur dis si vous en proposer une autre
et qui est une politique de gauche vous
aurais dit dans la ventre et j'ai des
appels sur tout et on verra ce qu ils
vous répondront mais non africains
aimablement et vous aurez conduire à
écouter christian paul n'a pas dit n'a
pas eu les mots violents à mon caca
urvoy tsonga a rendez-vous important
tous les cas ce sera le 22 mai puisque
les députés front de gauche vont déposer
une proposition de loi pour dire stop
aux négociations entre l'europe et les
états unis actuellement sur le libre
échange en va en parler dans un instant
est-ce qu'on va parler de votre combat
européen monsieur mélenchon et vous
appuyez notamment donc sur ce traité
transatlantique mais également sur le
dossier alstom dont convient d'évoquer
et on voit ça avec le reportage de
faustine saint-geniès avant d'accueillir
donc katell prigent de la fp en
solidarité
salariés cette entreprise à peine
quelques militants pour cette opération
qui se voulait coup de poing hier matin
le front de gauche présente ses têtes de
listes aux élections européennes pour
l'île de france devant le siège d'alstom
objectif pour le député européen patrick
le hyaric montrer que l'europe actuelle
va à l'encontre des intérêts de la
france
cette entreprise est un concentré de ce
que nous ne voulons pas c'est à dire les
effets de la mondialisation capitaliste
le fait que les institutions européennes
ne protège pas nos atouts des
industriels meeting des têtes de listes
à nanterre le front de gauche opte pour
un positionnement simple dans cette
campagne être la gauche opposée à
l'austérité
ici on récuse l'étiquette
d'eurosceptiques mais on fait de
l'europe un bouc émissaire c'est
l'europe des marchés c'est l'europe de
la finance ce que nous proposent leur
parlement c'est la dégringolade on
retombe dans la ruine rien de ce qui se
passe en l'état les engraisse pour moi
et socialistes actuels ne sont pas de
gauche a donc il n'y a que le champ
gauche pour y arriver
si la sortie de l'euro est
définitivement écarté le front de gauche
appellent à rompre et refondre l'europe
quitte à désobéir aux traités comme le
résume la numéro 2 sur la liste est
avocate de jean luc mélenchon raquel
garrido
nous sommes le nom de gauche du tc eu de
2005 où seul le nom de gauche à françois
hollande
et on est le non de gauche au grand
marché dans un camp situé le grand
marché transatlantique c'est d'ailleurs
le principal cheval de bataille du front
de gauche est farouchement opposé à ce
traité de libre échange entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis en cours de
négociation à bruxelles
difficile pourtant pour le parti de
faire entendre sa voix dans cette
campagne éclair à trois semaines à peine
des élections européennes
voilà qu'à tel présent est avec nous
bonsoir chers consoeur de la mp jean luc
mélenchon vous écoute et vous répond
alors viens de voir vous en avait déjà
parlé tout à l'heure avec michel sur
alstom
on y revient quand même de deux ans est
ce que l'état a raison de demander des
garanties supplémentaires à génériques
ça signifie qui capitule mois comprenez
c'est son point de vue c'est le point de
vue
des libéraux dans le style de hollande
ou de valse 10 rebonds dans les
entreprises et le marché vont régler
tout ça c'est pas mon point de vue moi
je suis pour qui un pôle public de
l'énergie dans lequel on sache produire
toutes les machines dont on a besoin
pour le grand plan écologique dont j'ai
besoin pour l'idée que je me fais du
développement écologique de notre pays
alors après si vous me posez la question
précise des garanties qu'ils demandent
je peux pas approuver une méthode qui
revient à admettre le fait que alstom
trabant du je ne le veux pas ce qui est
sûr c'est que entre les deux siemens et
general electric on peut dire la chose
suivante siemens et general electric en
pire
mais moi je ne veux pas de ça je vais
vous dire ça me fend le coeur je pense
en ce moment à cuenca une ville de
l'équateur alstom vient d'envoyer 80
travailleurs du très haut niveau on va
installer le tramway le plus gros
tramway d'amérique du sud
c'est de la vitrine des français en
amérique du sud imaginez-vous quand on
va leur dire de maintenance et le
tramway des gringos non c'est pas
possible on peut pas faire une chose
pareille
c'est la france que voulez vous c'est
l'identité industrielle de la france
bon sens la france elle et pas seulement
les parfums et la tour eiffel c'est une
industrie puissante c'est quelque chose
justement d'européens à ben certainement
pas siemens n'a pas l'intention de faire
quelque chose d'européens vous rêvez
d'autant qu'il y aura le grand marché
transatlantique donc tout ça ça n'existe
plus si même de faire du gros siemens et
que propose siemens de nous refiler son
train qui ne marche pas parce que la
vérité c'est qu'alstom bas siemens
chaque fois qu'il s'agit d'un contrat de
trains et vous avez cas ici de mon temps
entre un allemand fabriqué par siemens
et vous aurez une idée de ce que ça peut
être qu'un train aux arrivées et départs
aléatoires donc à siemens se débarrasse
de la branche la plus endettée et la
moins performante en échange de quoi ils
rachètent toute la branche énergie au
moment où le monde entier se prépare à
faire une bifurcation du modèle
énergétique
vous savez que la seule station d
owlient offshore c'est-à-dire en mer
posé sur des sur des piles qu'il y as en
face d'une côte des états unis
d'amérique
c'est alstom qui la réalise donc il
s'agit d'un dans fleuron quelque chose
qui est beau et grands qui nous permet
de développer des techniques les aciers
spéciaux les pales d'une turbine ccc
quelque chose comme pour six turbines de
deux barrages c'est des choses qui font
trois quatre cinq six sept mètres de
haut et c'est réglé au micro ce sont des
à ses fins donc c'est vraiment
c'est pas tout le dire alstom et un
plomb il faut se rendre compte de
l'intelligence technique a dans toutes
ses machines
pas question de lâcher ça aux autres
autres sujets européens qui vous est
cher le traité transatlantique
le 22 mai michel ladi le front de gauche
dépose une loi pour dire stop aux
négociations
c'est aussi un point où vous vous
rejoignez avec les écologistes
oui alors d'abord c'est la bonne
nouvelle parce qu'au départ les
écologistes n'étaient pas sur cette
position en 2002 vous savez d'abord
qu'on dise une chose cette histoire est
incroyable parce que ça se négocie
depuis 1995 et et personne n'a jamais
entendu parler si bien qu'en 2009
j'avais sorti une première brochure qui
est l'équivalent de celle qu'on vient de
rééditer
mais au bout d'un moment je me suis dit
mais c'est moi qui dois exagérer ce pas
possible personne n'en parle ça
n'intéresse personne
et puis tout d'un coup en janvier 2013
le président obama doit faire un grand
marché et à ce moment-là d'affaires
s'est accélérée et à ce moment-là marché
en train de l'europe et des états doit
là un marché unique où il y aurait un
peu comme on a fait en adressant aux as
on a des choses à gagner
non un peu comme on a fait entre les 28
non mais je termine de répondre ensuite
je vous réponds mais déjà je vous
réponds non et je finis la répond la
bonne nouvelle c'est que les écologistes
au départ cohn bendit en 2002 a voté
pour
et maintenant les écologistes sont
contre on voit donc qu'il ya une
convergence qui s'opère entre le front
de gauche qui est sûr le nom depuis 2009
et les écolos veulent nouveau terrain où
on se retrouve ensemble sont surtout
sensibles aux questions d'environnement
bien sûr parce que les normes
environnementales seront les mêmes des
deux côtés de l'atlantique évidemment
c'est toujours être plus basse qui
prévalent parce que sinon ils font pas
un grand marché les américains font pas
ça pour introduire de la
social-démocratie aux usa donc les
normes environnementales seront les plus
basses pour nous les européens c'est
grave parce que ça veut dire les
produits ogm ça veut dire le boeuf aux
hormones ça veut dire on sort toujours
cet exemple parce qu'ils sont un peu
sourire nous nous l'avons les poulets
tuer avec nos méthodes on excelle à voir
avec les normes sanitaires en matière
d'alimentation sont excusés de ce faux
et ben écoutez je sais pas qui vous a
dit ça à la lame à stocker le candidat
ump d'alors je ne sais pas si j'ai un
ump qui le dit c'est donc que c'est vrai
mais en attendant le commissaire
européen chargé de la question a dit
qu'il fallait arrêter de l'embêter avec
cette histoire de poulet lavea
j'avais aux états unis d'amérique parce
que m'avait pas laissée terminée et il a
dit eh bien il y aura qu'à mettre des
étiquettes et ceux qui voudront pas de
poulet à la javel montgeron les autres
mais le poulet javel coûtera
nécessairement moins cher pour la raison
qu'il est nettoyée avec des méthodes
je vous fais grâce du détail donc les
écolos sont sensibles à ça nous aussi
nous avons une divergence avec eux c'est
qu'on leur dit bah écoutez comment on
pourrait vous être sensible à
l'alignement par le bas des normes et en
même temps voté toutes les mesures de
libéralisation du marché de l'énergie
bon on a des contradictions je peux dire
on ne dit pas les choses de la même
manière nous nous sommes absolument
contre le libre-échange et lost et non
attendez de quoi nous sommes pas contre
tous nous sommes pour la mairie nous
sommes pour le bonheur nous sommes liés
dans les propositions parce qu'on dit
que la définition des normes
essentielles jean luc mélenchon pourrait
on connaît conquérir des marchés voilà
c'est ça qu'on crée alors et ça c'est
faux c'est oui c'est absurde mais
monsieur gossio on a peut-être quand
même le droit de se demander si c'est
une bonne idée de créer un marché unique
est ce qu'on a le droit ou pas est-ce
que c'est évident est ce que le but dans
la vie c'est de développer les parts de
marché sur le dos de qui s'il vous plaît
vous savez très bien que ce ne sont pas
les normes qui empêche les parts de
marché l'énorme servent de barrage
protectionnistes aux états unis face à
l'europe l'europe a abaissé toutes ses
frontières
toutes ces barrières d'accord donc de
quoi parle-t-on de celle des états unis
d'amérique donc le but dans la vie c'est
d'entrer sur le marché des états unis
d'amérique mais nous y sommes déjà
je vous ferai remarquer et nous
pourrions nous mettre des normes
environnementales qui empêchent certains
produits d'entrée en europe donc s'il
vous plaît de grâce ne retournez pas la
situation avec le cette espèce de tarte
à la crème ce refrain d'après lequel dès
qu'on crée un grand marché ça développe
la croissance l'activité l'emploi bla
bla bla bla rien de tout ça ne s'est
jamais produit je suis parlementaire
européen j'ai vu passer au moins 15
accords de libre échange avec telle ou
telle zone du monde à chaque foyer
marquer nous aurons un point de
croissance 052 si on faisait le total on
serait à 50 % de croissance qui serait
vraiment très mauvais pour la planète
rien de tout ça ne se produira la vérité
que les nord américains veulent créer un
grand marché unique parce que depuis
tantôt 30 ans ils ont un objectif
constituer un bloc occidental et c'est
ça leur objectif et géopolitique
il n'est pas économique parce que rien
aujourd'hui n'a empêché les amériques
en acheter des entreprises françaises
les entreprises françaises d'acheter des
entreprises américaines donc du point de
vue du capital il n'y a pas de problème
c'est du point de vue du travail et de
la qualité de vie qui aura un très grand
problème
alstom le traité transatlantique est ce
que quand même le pouvoir politique
encore du poids bien sûr on pouvoir
économique évidemment sauf s'il renonce
alstom par exemple nous pourrions
décider que c'est une entreprise
stratégique
il ya des lois qui permettent de dire ah
bah écoutez la france intervient on
n'est pas agressif on dit assis mains
sur vous remercie d'avoir fait une offre
on dit à general electric on vous
remercie d'avoir fait une sur le titre
general electric est une entreprise très
implanté en france donc il n'est pas
question de se mettre en guerre avec
general electric et puis on dit mais
alstom au sol garde et on crée
d'ailleurs en pôle public
on pourrait créer un pôle public marié
avec cette entreprise dont le nom
m'échappe à l'instant qui fabrique des
aciers spéciaux et qui elle aussi est en
liquidation
or c'est assez spéciaux sont nécessaires
pour de telles réalisations etc
et c'est donc le l'intervention de
l'état est toujours possible c'est la
capitulation qui fait qu'il y en a pas
mais personne n'oblige hollande à ne pas
intervenir
au contraire si j'étais moi le
responsable de la politique du pays
cette affaire serait réglé de même qu
alcatel n'aurait jamais été m ces
brevets en garantie à goldman sach mieux
au contraire l'état aurait un milliard
et demi de capital engagé dans cette
entreprise
voilà il n'ya de le libéralisme ne tombe
pas du ciel
le marché ne tombe pas du ciel il est
volontairement organisé par des gens qui
pensent que c'est comme ça que
l'humanité va mieux et moi je crois
qu'ils font une absurdité
permettez moi qu'un de rajouter un ou
écologique qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire alors donc maintenant déménagé
le monde transbahuter des marchandises
d'un côté à l'autre de l'atlantique
c'est ça l'avenir un monde fini dans les
ressources sont finies et tout ce qui
nous intéresse est déménagée circulait
produire à moindre prix augmenter la
taille des navires qui transportent de
plus en plus se réjouir de voir la
calotte glaciaire fonde parce que les
navires de plus en plus large peuvent
passer par la féliciter bien l'instant
dcexel exportations d'alstom mais pardon
ça n'est pas pareil qu'une entreprise
installe parce que elle qu'elle installe
ses productions qui sont des productions
comme comme des éoliennes aux états unis
et d'organiser le des ménages
au général du monde mais maintenant
monsieur grossiord je veux bien vous
dire que nous pourrions décider que le
matériel énergétique ne s'exporte pas ce
serait absurde parce que des millions de
gens ont besoin de ce matériel et ne
sont pas en état de le produire par
contre permettez moi de vous dire que
des poulets tout le monde peut en
produire et que le riz tout le monde
n'est pas obligé d'en manger le blé tout
le monde n'est pas obligé d'en manger
parce qu'il ya des pays où ça serait
mieux de plantes et du sorgho et
continuer les cultures traditionnelles
qui seront écrasés par ses exportations
voilà voilà la vérité comme on a bien
compris les différents combats que vous
menez dans la perspective de ce scrutin
européen cas également
vous n'avez pas bien compte c'est ce que
est ce que je peux dire quels sont les
réseaux mpg votre brochure
merci merci je vais prochainement sur
donc en fait on vote trois choses pardon
on peut avoir des débats sans fin sur
l'europe et donc on connaît cette
transition sur françois hollande par
exemple est-ce que vous déplorez aussi
que ce matin il n'est pas parlé d'europe
justement à bord je pense que il aurait
dû on voit bien que pour lui c'est un
non sujet puisque toute façon on n'aura
pas fait ce que dit madame merkel donc
pour lui ce pas un sujet je déplore
l'abaissement de sa pensée parce que
quand on a en tout et pour tout comme
slogan plus vite plus fort qu'on le
répète cinq fois bon et on est pauvre
jeux olympiques là on n'est pas en train
d'organiser une course on est en train
d'organiser la vie d'un pays et
deuxièmement l'abaissement de sa pensée
quand il dit l'entreprise france non la
france n'est pas une entreprise ne se
gère pas comme une entreprise
ce n'est pas vrai que la france a failli
déposer son bilan c'est un mensonge
la france n'est pas du tout en état de
déposer un bilan la france est plus
riche qu'elle n'a jamais été de toute
son histoire
ils essayent de nous passer le
vocabulaire de la droite économique et
je trouve déplorable de la part d'un
président de la république alors pour
les élections pardon de vous dire nous
avons cette fois ci un contenu concret
chaque député votera oui ou non au grand
marché transatlantique ce n'est pas le
cas avant mais là il va voter
deuxièmement chaque député devra choisir
un président de la commission soit c'est
monsieur juncker prototype du libéral
soit c'est ce martin schulz socialiste
qui gouverne avec madame merkel en
allemagne soit c'est monsieur bové soit
c'est monsieur type race le héros de la
résistance grecque que nous soutenons
nous comme candidat à l'élection à la
commission européenne bien comme la
question dernière petite question
marine le pen qui dit
voir constituer une minorité de blocage
pour éviter l' austérité qui table sur
20 à 25 députés européens le front de
gauche en a contre 34,4 elle a des
espoirs de gallas et payons pour l
électoralement de dénoncer l'austérité
pourquoi cette différence bon d'abord
commençons par dire si vous voulez bien
que pour l'instant ils sont trois et
nous 5
non mais parce que vous comparer notre
situation actuelle avec leurs espoirs de
demain donc c'est juste pour rétablir
l'information de croissance 8 oui oui
bien sûr oui oui on a compris on a
compris vous inquiétez pas on a bien
compris ce que vous cherchez à faire
alors ensuite nous avons écouté monsieur
vous comparez une réalité d'aujourd'hui
avec une projection pour demain alors
oui c'est bien ce que vous venez de
faire ça m'amuse moi ça me contrarie
oui oui alors maintenant on va regarder
n'ont rien donné comment pourquoi you
mais réputé mois il supporter que où
vous des masques de temps à autre
maintenant on annonce
il est dit que le groupe b auquel
j'appartiens pourrait être le troisième
de cette assemblée
cette information qui n'est pas sur un
bien sûr c'est un sondage comme pour
madame le pen raille oui voilà donc
c'est un sondage mais en attendant on
dit que le groupe b pour être le
troisième est donc la candidature
d'alexis prince prendra tout de suite un
impact dans le parlement européen qui
sera considérable après là vous me posez
la question de savoir pourquoi elle
s'est aussi contre l'austérité
ce dont je me réjouis elle qui est aussi
contre le grand marché transatlantique
ce dont je me réjouis parce que fait
madame le pen sur ces sujets en quelque
sorte
elle élargit le consensus national
hostile à l'autorité hostile aux
politiques libérales hostiles au grand
marché transatlantique et aux états unis
d'amérique
je n'ai quand même pas pleurer bon alors
pourquoi elle at elle des sondages
meilleurs que les nôtres
eh bien peut-être monsieur grossiord
pourriez-vous je sais pas à tout hasard
un os comme ça constaté qu'il ya une
différence entre une organisation de
gauche est une organisation d'extrême
droite déjà ça fait une différence
la deuxième différence c'est que eux
sont là le lobby le pen père fils et
petites filles et petits et arrière
petits enfants depuis 40 ans nous nous
existons depuis cinq ans deuxièmement
même traversons à mesure que nous
avançons des difficultés d'ajustement de
stratégie qui fait que des fois on est
un peu illisible je ne vais pas dire le
contraire
donc ce sont nos difficultés et enfin
nous ne sommes pas racistes nous ne
sommes pas être des cistes et par
conséquent il est plus difficile de
comprendre que le responsable de nos
malheurs c'est le financier
le banquier plutôt que de croire que
celle immigrés madame le pen dispose à
son à son service du simplisme et de la
haine des autres bombes a apparemment
son fond de commerce est là mais dois-je
devenir raciste ethniciste pour réussir
non jamais et vous avez vu que dans mon
discours de mme strager vous avez vu
dans mon discours de marseille en pleine
campagne présidentielle
j'ai dit ce qu'il y avait à dire s'étend
à l'avenir de la france et des mélanges
dont l effet avec voir arthur sur la
méditerranée on se souvient de ce
discours merci katell c'est perrine
tarneaud arrive maintenant on va parler
notamment de l'ukraine un dossier très
sensible et très important également des
attaques contre leurs lancées contre des
journaux les agissements de certains de
nos confrères
selon vous d'abord jce manqué à c'est le
mot d'abord question de style de jean
luc mélenchon le tribun en quête de
samir déchira je suis curieux de voir ça
s'il le faut nous viserons le maire du
palais qu'ils s'en aillent tous
c'est le tribun par excellence des
discours de plusieurs heures sans notes
mais truffé de références
jean luc mélenchon excelle dans l'art de
fasciner son auditoire
il a toujours été un des meilleurs
orateurs du parti socialiste parce
qu'elle a le sens de la formule et puis
il a le sens de la gestuelle jean luc
mélenchon c'est un tribun nos quais au
sens de la 3ème et la 4ème république
c'est quelqu'un qui met beaucoup
d'émotion donc ce quelqu'un qui met de
la colère en particulier cette colère là
on fait elle est en phase avec ce
qu'attendent les gens aujourd'hui il ya
une très forte colère dans la société
française une colère qui s'exprime aussi
sur les plateaux télé hyper médiatique
jean luc mélenchon sait faire le buzz à
coups de formules chocs
est ce que vous vous êtes prêt à
déclarer votre patrimoine pour qu'on
s'assure que rien dans votre patrimoine
fait que vous êtes gêné pour me poser
certaines questions écouté mon espèce
d'hypocrites de médias il ya une
stratégie médiatique
j'arrive mélenchon à tort à mon avis
parce qu'il a de meilleur qualité que
cela choisit souvent la transe
région c'est-à-dire frapper fort ont
frappé les imaginations et donc du coup
ça amène un discours qui porte en lui
une certaine violence et marine le pen
main par tant d'autres prémices aussi un
discours violent une violence commune
dans le discours mais la comparaison
s'arrête là car du côté de jean luc
mélenchon pas de simplification à
l'extrême dans la formulation il ya eu
des tas fait qu'un marine le pen les
gens vous moi tout le monde comprend et
comprennent 80 % de ce que dit marine le
pen spontanément sans avoir besoin de
réfléchir avec que jean luc mélenchon
parce que son vocabulaire est élaborée
parce que ces références sont
compliquées élitiste ça va tomber à 16
18 20 % donc si vous voulez entre 80 %
et 20 % il ya quand même un gros gros
gap et c'est ça qui explique que jean
luc mélenchon n'arrive pas à embrayer
avec l'électorat en général c'est que il
n'est pas au bon niveau
tribun populaire mais peut-être pas
assez populistes une différence qui pèse
son poids dans les résultats électoraux
aux européennes du 25 mai le front
national est donnée en tête bien devant
le front de gauche
voilà j'ai avec mêlant chant et c'est
perrine tarneaud qui vous interroge
maintenant mais non vous ne simplifiée
pas assez finalement jean luc mélenchon
est ce que vous partagez cette analyse
j'ai d'abord c'est une analyse qui est
respectueuse donc je la gelée coûte
j'entends ce qu'on dit mais vous savez
en pleine campagne présidentielle
j'avais eu une petite remarque de
quelqu'un que j'estime en dépit du fait
que je ne suis pas d'accord avec tout
comme alain bergounioux qui est un
esprit extrêmement puissants dans le
mouvement socialiste c'était madame mona
ozouf qui avait dit mélenchon est trop
intellectuel pour ceux à qui il parle
je pense qu'elle se trompe le grand
nombre des français comprend
parfaitement ce qui se dit et c'est un
peuple libre donc il choisit d'un côté
ou de l'autre
et comme réplique à madame mona ozouf
que je respecte encore une fois
brillante historienne j'avais dit aux
gens et écouter ce soir à faire ce que
personne fait je vais vous lire en
poèmes
j'ai eu deux pages de poésie de victor
et vos légendes les yeux qui brillaient
ont applaudi à tout rompre
victor hugo bien sûr pas moi mais
surtout l'idée que quelqu'un ne les
prenais pas présent mais s'il faut pas
prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
il nous avons un sujet je croyais que je
suis riche compréhensible alors oui je
pense que je pense que je suis
compréhensible j'admets que les idées
que je développe par contre nécessite
des fois j'en suis confus par c'est pour
ça que je parte en deux temps justice
babar dans mes meetings
parce que j'essaye d'expliquer tout bien
en détails parce que je me dis mais les
gens n'ont pas ils n'ont pas que ça à
faire dans la journée
c'est pour ça qu'ils m'ont élu c'est
pour leur expliquer donc je fais le
travail après que voulez vous c'est la
lente
le lent travail de l'histoire l'histoire
est lente et cruel c'est bien le
problème mais nous les gens de gauche
nous avons toujours été à creuser le
sillon dans les difficultés vous savez
les moments de gloire ont été rares dans
l'histoire on arrive au gouvernement de
temps à auch par la gauche à paris où
elle est devenu sauvage
vous voyez c'est à dire que vous êtes
vite installée dans un rôle vous êtes
vite poussé au bout de vous même il ya
des méthodes de travail de 2 du
journalisme qui pousse les gens à bout
de mer on n'est pas toujours préparés à
ça vous comprenez quand par exemple
certains certains comme des rémissions
leur truc c'est d'être présent de vous
coller un micro sous le nez toute la
journée où vous posez dix fois la même
question jusqu'à ce que vous craquiez
moi je reconnais je n'ai pas le nerfs
d'acier je ne suis pas encore devenu le
robot qu'il faudrait être pour faire
face à cette situation j'ai le tort de
me passionner jeu j'en conviens mais je
me passionne c'est ce qui explique que
cette semaine encore si on va doubler
que vous en êtes très aux journalistes
du monde et de libération du monde
seulement ouais enfin libération vous
les citer aussi vous vous appelez en
tout cas concernant le journalisme les
journalistes du monde
vous appelez vos amis c'est ce que vous
dites sur votre blog elle est surveillée
de façon étroite et à filmer parce que
c'est big brother c'est enfin écoutez
c'est big brother pour moi toute la
journée il ya des cas mais ça va le ce
sont des militants politiques le monde
mène une action permanente contre moi
des photos diffamante insultante 30 fois
le même portrait de moi publié dans
leurs différentes éditions çà va donc le
monde a une position politique c'est un
militant politique ce journal dont il
reçoit une réponse de militants j'ai
essayé vous savez de faire la paix avec
de trouver un modus vivendi je vais vous
dire comment j'ai proposé trois
conditions pour avoir un entretien chez
eux
1 un type qui a un rapport avec le sujet
de une photo qui ne soit pas insultante
3 la moitié des questions sur la
deuxième tente par exemple une photo où
on va me durcir tous les traits me
prendre en gros plan au moment où je
chante l'internationale j'ai donc la
bouche grande ouverte et on voit jusqu'à
mes chaussettes dans ma bouche et à des
photos ou insultant je n'ai pas amené le
document si vous m'aviez dit que vous
m'interrogez sur le sujet je vous
l'aurais montrer je n'ai pas supporté
d'être mis à la une du monde dans les
mêmes positions hors adorateurs et une
bande comme comme comme celle d' adolf
hitler je n'ai pas supporté
je suis un homme de gauche on a le droit
de détester toutes mes idées mais pas
d'insultés ma personne ni de n'avoir
aucun respect pour ma dignité dans le
cas qui nous occupe
pourquoi j'ai réagi une fois de plus
parce que mon camarade gabriel a marqué
la tête de liste dans la région du grand
est et allait démarrer le démarrage de
sa caravane devant alstom alors ils ont
discuté avec les gens ils ont comme on
le fait rien que de très normal en plus
vous vous doutez que dans le sport dans
l'instant nous avons beaucoup d'amis non
c'est pas celui ci c'était une autre
situation là-bas à belfort bon vous vous
doutez qu'il ya beaucoup de gens du
front de gauche à l'intérieur de
d'alstom s'est passé pas une découverte
dont claire la ration très bonne et par
quoi commence le papier par le fait
qu'on est mal garées que ça gêne les
ouvriers bon ça va dans l'arctique est
ce que c'est vrai ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour dire que c'est blessant
monsieur grossiord quand vous désirez
être jugé tout l'image est enfin monté
sur des titres digbeu ce cas ce n'est
pas d'aujourd'hui kheraj et ça n'est pas
dangereux demandez à vos militants de
d'entraver le travail de nos confrères
mais on n'en trouve pas est ce que mon
travail est entravée par le fait qu'on
me colle une caméra toute la journée du
matin au soir
comme leur lot fait à plusieurs reprises
et dans une émission ben oui ce sont des
militants républicains qui vous en
gagnant attendez moi je suis un homme
public à une activité publique
donc je n'accepte pas d'être insultée
dans ma dimension d'homme oui mais les
journalistes ne vous suivent pas non
plus dans votre vie privée laïque
oui madame parce que les avocats qu'il
fallait pour ça figurez vous n'est ce
pas parce que j'ai envoyé les avocats
qu'il fallait pour sa part parce qu'ils
se sont eux-mêmes censuré vous retenu
par donc nous reste une morale vous
assumez
j'assume pleinement six ans d'être
monsieur messieurs grossiord j'assume je
suis dans une mêlée avec le journal le
monde
nous sommes dans une dispute il ya une
disproportion des moyens gigantesques
vis-à-vis du monde a bien sûr que c'est
de cette nature c'est pour leur dire une
fois de plus un raid ailleurs avec le
journal le monde a un problème de en
interne et madame nougarède qui le
dirige crois qu'elle va s'en sortir en
montrant à un ennemi commun
monsieur jean-luc dizier un peu épuisé
par la politique française prêt à jeter
l'épongé
non je rêve il m'a dit vous avez l'air
épuisé j'ai dit oui je le suis enfin
j'ai 63 ans et je cours le pays toute
l'année on peut comprendre que je sois
fatigué de la révolte à l'est et au sud
est qui plonge le pays qui plonge des
annonces à la presse l'ambiance vous
avez vu comment les facistes ont fait
brûler des camarades à l'intérieur de la
maison des syndicats
c'est une honte ouais mais poutine a
réussi son opération de déstabilisation
non en ukraine sur mac mais non les
etats-unis sont arrivés mais sont
dépassés par la situation
alors je sais je connais le numéro je
suis poutinien blabla mettons ça de côté
si on réfléchit sérieusement nous avons
dans cette région du monde la fin de l'
empire soviétique n'a jamais été
négociés
donc les choses se recale on a un
terrain et faire preuve d'intelligence
et doux d'esprit pacifique
n'est ce pas c'est le contraire de la
méthode qu'on pratique et les états unis
d'amérique en essayant d'avancer les
frontières de l'otan jusqu'aux portes
des bases russe en crimée bien et ce à
partir d'aujourd'hui en essayant de
faire avancer les frontières bardot
c'est aussi ce qu'essaie de faire la
russie aujourd'hui la rdc mortes et on
n'est pas cet avis sinon vous n'avez pas
droit parce que ce n'est pas vrai
l'initiative d' étendre les frontières
de l'otan à l'intérieur de l'ukraine de
la crimée n'est pas venue d'une
initiative virus mais des nord
américains
il se trouve qu'une nouvelle fois en
ukraine comme en géorgie
ils sont débordés par des
ultranationalistes au départ en ukraine
on a une révolte populaire que je
soutiens une révolution sociale contre
les oligarques qui est pourri et les
corrompus qui sont revenus au pouvoir
effectivement quelques nationale
estaing oui six ministres d'extrême
droite nationaux socialistes c'est en
détail
imaginez que la même chose arrive chez
monsieur poutine et on verrait ce que
vous diriez alors qu'a fait monsieur
poutine je ne dis pas qu'il a raison il
a fait quelque chose que je l'admets pas
qu'ils aient de transgresser les
frontières
je suis pour qu'on ne touche pas aux
frontières donc si vous me demandez mon
avis accord je ne suis pas pour l'entrée
en ukraine mais je dis que le
raisonnement qui consiste à chauffer
matin midi et soir l'opinion contre la
russie en le désignant comme un
adversaire est une bêtise
nous avons nous les français autre chose
à faire je vous signale que le nombre de
responsables internationaux qui
commencent à dire que cette histoire est
en train de mal tourner et que c'est pas
une bonne idée d'aller se battre au
milieu des centrales nucléaires lui il
faut il faut par nos solutions saas et
ce en sciences économiques de l'estrade
sur les sanctions économiques sont
ridicules et absurdes qui propose une
médiation
c'est bien mais les sanctions
économiques qui frappent tel ça ne fera
pas la russie c'est une c'est un pays
gigantesque ça nous frappe nous les
européens parce que les allemands des
milliards d'investissements en russie
parce que nous les français
les banques françaises possèdent des
réseaux les entreprises s'inquiètent
dont deuxième place sur la suite
la situation est absurde parce que c'est
une guerre civile au milieu de centrales
nucléaires dois-je rappeler comment la
dernière fois on a réglé le cas de
tchernobyl des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de russes sont allé mourir pour
empêcher le corps de d'exploser et toute
l'europe d'être contaminé par conséquent
ce n'est pas être un poutinien que de
dire qu'il ne faut pas faire la guerre
il ne faut pas faire la guerre il faut
négocier qu'il faut faire des
concessions aussi au risque mais non non
aucune autre que la garantie de leurs
frontières
vous n'avez qu'à lire ce qu'ils écrivent
on ne peut pas lire que ce que dit
monsieur john kerry monsieur john kerry
a dit que la question ukrainienne mettez
en cause l'hégémonie des etats-unis dans
le monde madame est ce que c'est ça que
vous défendez non bien sûr ni moi non
plus nous ne défendons pas l'hégémonie
des nord américains dans l'ain nous
descendons la paix la tranquillité et le
développement harmonieux des peuples est
un pacifiste
évidemment je suis un pacifique absolue
et radicale pas un pacifiste parce que
des fois il faut défendre sa vie les
armes à la main mais je dis que ce qui
se passe en blanc en ukraine
cette absurde d'aller soutenir les
éléments les plus déchaînés bien sûr que
les russes agissent et se donnent des
garanties bien sûr bien sûr qu'on ne
doit pas approuvé le fait qu'il viole
les frontières mais en attendant il faut
comprendre pourquoi il agit de cette
manière si vous voulez qu'une médiation
abouti si vous pensez que c'est
seulement de l'impérialisme vous ne
comprenez rien à la situation
les russes veulent se garantir et les
nord-américains les agresse voilà le
fond de la sphère remédier il ya
l'europe quand même il ya un peuple
ukrainien une partie en tous les cas qui
aspire qui déclasse en axant sa flamme
pour l'europe ça très bien vous avez
aussi la plaine la passion de l'avenir
le nord fait non pas un monde on n'en
croyait pas un mot l'ukraine
certainement pas certainement pas nous
allons intégrer l'ukraine à l'union
européenne c'est ça que vous ne dites
pas du tout et ça vous proposez pardon
qu'est-ce que l'ukraine viendrait faire
dans l'union européenne n'a pas de la
turquie
on va faire entrer l'ukraine c'est à
dire on ne veut pas d'un pays développé
comme la turquie pour les raisons que
vous connaissez
moi j'en ai une deux fois pour pas
vouloir à turquie je ne veux pas car ils
80 millions de gens qui sera à des
conditions sociales inférieur au niveau
moyen de l'europe parce que le jumping
sera développé pour les mêmes raisons je
ne veux pas des ukrainiens et je ne suis
pas d'accord pour dire que nous aurions
l'obligation de prendre en charge une
ukraine dévasté par sa propre bêtise
très bien voilà qui est dit est dit
beaucoup de choses tout est dit ou
presque avec mel originaire merci noël à
la prochaine fois oui à bientôt
bien sûr
hu